bonsoir nous sommes le 14 avril nouvelle
édition du 7 8 politique votre mensuel
dans un instant je recevrai les quatre
candidats têtes de liste à l'élection
municipale partielle de
voisins-le-bretonneux ils ont tous
décidé de se maintenir pour le second
tour de dimanche la sortante alexandra
rosetti est en ballottage favorable avec
48,81 % des suffrages on parle tout
d'abord des régionales de 2015 et c'est
officiel depuis quelques heures les
élections se dérouleront les 6 et 13
décembre en ile-de-france deux
candidates déclaré chantal jouanno pour
lui d ea et valérie pécresse pour l'ump
pas d'alliance pour le moment bien que
cette dernière ils soient plutôt
favorable elle l'a répété lors du
lancement de sa campagne en
seine-saint-denis le 11 avril 2000
personnes présentes et quel que soit son
adversaire à gauche elle est plutôt
confiance est confiante écoutez
vous savez je pense qu'il ya une envie
d'alternance une envie de changement la
région ile de france c'est le moteur de
l'avion france et si nous changeons la
région jeu j'en ferai un laboratoire de
l'alternance avec moins d'impôts avec
plus de logements plus de transport et
puis aussi plus d'emplois et pendant que
valérie pécresse lancé sa campagne le
maire de coignières se retirer de son
poste henri pailleux élu pour la
première fois en 1986 a décidé de
démissionner fatigué de la politique il
restera conseiller municipal mais
dorénavant c'est jean-pierre sevestre
qui endosse le costume de premier
magistrat henri paillet invités du
prochain café politique de téléphiles à
l'antenne samedi et dimanche 19h30 voici
un court extrait et il évoque son
successeur le reste au conseil municipal
mais c'est assez logique et c'est normal
mais je ne reste pas là je dirais pour
surveiller
ça s'appelle le jean percevait ce nom
bien évidemment je pourrais lui sur ce
qu'il va faire je ne pense pas qu'il
sorte je dirais du 4 tel que je n'ai
tracé depuis 30 ans enfin après tout on
ne sait jamais et donc je serai là je
dirais pour garantir ou essayer de
garantir la continuité mais je n'ai pas
d'inquiétude j'en percevais c'est un
garçon sérieux c'est un bosseur et donc
qu est à présent sur le terrain
également et je pense qu'il a toutes les
qualités pour gérer on en vient au débat
de ce soir l'élection municipale
partielle à voisins le bretonneux second
tour ce dimanche et 19 avril les quatre
listes étaient en position de se
maintenir leurs représentants vont à
présent échangé pendant une vingtaine de
minutes
alexandra rosetti et tête de liste vivre
voisin est divers droite thierry gastaud
tête de liste voisins ma vie le divers
droite jean h est tête de liste pour
voisins avec vous union de la gauche et
olivier affonso tête de liste tous
rassemblés pour voisin divers droite
bonsoir à tous les quatre vos
interventions qui seront chronométrés
afin de veiller à l'équilibré des temps
de parole et pour commencer vos
réactions à chacun sur ce premier tour
brièvement alexandra rosetti vous êtes
arrivé avec en tête avec un ballotage
plutôt favorable 48,8 % vous auriez
préféré une élection dès le premier tour
c'est vrai que si on avait pu ces
familles un deuxième tour je pense que
tout le monde aurait été content mais
après avec quatre listes s'arrêter quand
même un exploit moi je suis évidemment
très contente et puis je pense que sa
marque ça témoigne en tout cas la
confiance des électeurs et puis c'est
une forme de récompense déjà pour nous
du travail engagé depuis un an avec mon
équipe à 17,53 % au premier tour pour la
liste de thierry gastaud où l'on trouve
notamment alexis piette l'ancien maire
qui siégeaient avant alexandra rosetti
c'est lui qui avait fait appel
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'il ya un
nouveau scrutin aujourd'hui 17 53% pour
vous c'est encourageant c'est une
déception ah bah écoute et lorsqu'on est
porteur d'un projet et d'une dynamique
jamais assez récompensés par les
électeurs ont sûrement espérer faire
mieux maintenant à droite on a fait le
choix de renouveler les têtes de listes
à voir une nouvelle génération c'est une
campagne extrêmement courte c'est aussi
difficile d'imposer des nouveaux visages
dans une campagne où il n'a pas fallu
faire en trois semaines ce qu'on fait
peut-être des fois en trois mois donc
vous venez de dire vous venez de dire à
droite vers précisé qu'il ya eu
d'investiture ni pour l'ump n'est pour
lui d y est juste parce que je l'avais
pas fait on après introduction mais à
droite également olivier affonso vous
avez réalisé 16 76% c'est la première
fois que vous présentiez mois les
scrutins municipal aussi à
voisins-le-bretonneux ce score là
s'avoue satisfait et la question juste
derrière c'est pourquoi ya pas de fusion
entre vos fils par exemple je
n'attendais pas cette question
d'abord c'est le succès du terrain c'est
à dire qu'à partir du moment où vous
avez des personnes qui avec ayrault pour
qui qui qui seront issues du terrain qui
vous parlent de choses concrètes
la moire l'occurrence j'ai fait une
campagne purement terrain et le score ce
qui me surprend n'est pas mon score je
m'attendais franchement avoir un le
score que j'ai eu dimanche je
m'attendais pas à voir un score aussi
serré sur les trolls et les deux autres
je vois que je suis à huit voix près de
la gauche vie sinoise dans son ensemble
à 39 voix près de l'équipe de thierry
gastaud avec l'ancien maire de
voisins-le-bretonneux c'est
véritablement un succès alors pourquoi
n'y a pas eu de fusion juste parce que
j'ai défendu un programme parce que
j'estime que les alliances contre nature
c'est pas mon c'est pas mon truc je fais
pas de la politique pour un poste je
fais c'est contre nature vos programmes
sont pas compatibles des moindres est
malade accord thierry gastou des fonds
la densification pur et dur de notre
ville le centre village il est porteur
d'un bilan celui d'alexis byette
suffit de voir ce qui a été fait au
centre village et lors de notre débat
que nous avons collé sur eux non chez
vos confrères de radio sensations il a
clairement manifesté son souhait de
continuer l'oeuvre de son
j'allais dire mentor le prédécesseur en
tout cas de madame rosetti je suis pas
dans ça on va y venir sur l'urbanisme
vous faire réagir sur le fait qu'ils
aient pas une fusion brièvement aurait
par grèce qu' un problème encore des
goûts ou peut être de tension entre
anciens élus qui mal à passer sur les
rivalités du passé moi je pense pour en
avoir discuté ensemble qu'on avait un
programme qui était relativement
compatibles même si c'est vrai on a une
divergence sur d'urbanisme du centre
ville où je pense qu'il faut aussi faire
preuve de réalisme on va parler
d'urbanisme justement tout d'abord la
réaction de gens achètent tête de liste
pour voisins avec vos l'union de la
gauche l'union de la gauche c'est 16,91
% sur ce premier doit absolument alors
moi je relèverai d'abord le taux
d'abstention qui pour moi était
dramatiquement élevé et je le regrette
énormément je pense d'ailleurs choses
allaient revenir aux urnes encore yamaha
départemental il ya longtemps qu'ils
avaient eu
150 à 200 votants de plus sur wii qu'un
tour donc je regrette ce taux
d'abstention là c'est ça notre score
j'espérais faire plus pour être très
sincère j'espérais qu'on atteigne 20 % à
17 % bon on va pas pinailler sur les
chiffres mais mais le constat du premier
tour est pour moi très simple entre les
trois listes de droite qui se présente
les vigiles ont clairement exprimé leur
accord pour qu'alexandre arrêts
rosetti soit réélu donc l'enjeu du
deuxième tour c'est qu'elle sera la
liste leader de l'opposition il n'est
que là et nous allons reparler ce soir
j'aurai l'occasion de revenir alors
quelques sujets pouvant faire réagir
pour échanger peut-être convaincre les
électeurs qui hésitaient qui ne se sont
pas déplacés aux urnes près d'un
électeur sur deux votre vision pour
voisins le bretonneux votre mise notre
vision pour ce mandat en terme
d'urbanisme déjà se retrouve forcément
dans chacun de vos programmes alexandra
rosetti vous avez déjà arrêté certains
projets qui avaient été menées par
alexis byette mais il faudra pour autant
construire du logement social la loi
impose 25% on n'était qu'à 16% sur
voisins-le-bretonneux du logement tout
court aussi on a entendu valérie
pécresse tout à l'heure qui disait que
il fallait construire du logement ce
matin j'étais au conseil départemental
et c'est un gros sujet parce que l'état
se prépare à nous imposer des choses
absolument catastrophique donc il va
falloir faire preuve de ténacité pour
gérer résister à tout ce qui nous attend
moi j'avais entamé un travail sur le
centre village avec les habitants pour
justement dans le cadre de l'évolution
du plan local d'urbanisme intercommunal
pour justement envisager l'avenir et
voir quelles comment on faisait évoluer
nos règles d'urbanisme pour que notre
centre village garde justement ce côté
plus village tout en étant réaliste
comme disait monsieur gastaud parce que
les promoteurs quand ils veulent acheter
un terrain privé on ne peut pas les
empêcher de construire dessus donc
l'idée c'est de haut - d'apposer des
règles qui fasse que ce qui va être
construit je dirais correspondent à
l'image qu'on veut avoir du centre je
pense juste pour exemple le maire le
programme numérotés où je connais
quelqu'un qui a un mur de 12 mètres de
haut qui est grèce qui se dresse au fond
de son jardin je pense pas que ce soit
ça qu'on veuille je dirais pour les
policiers est votre regard sur le
programme de d'alexandra rosetti et puis
des de votre concurrent mais aussi sur
ce qui a été fait depuis un an et qui a
aussi permis de stopper certains des
projets qui avaient été lancées par
alexis y est moi je crois que tout ce
qui a été réalisée elle a plutôt été
bien réalisé dans la continuité de ce
qui a été fait à voisins qu'on a
construit le centre ville il ya une
quinzaine d'années ça aussi effrayé
aujourd'hui s'est très bien intégré et
ça plaît à tous les six mois moi je
l'inscris dans le projet tel qu'il était
prévu programmé dans un projet
d'urbanisme avec une vision à long terme
un urbanisme maîtrisé
moi ce qui me ce qui porte c'est un
programme de projet et pas un programme
de promesses quand on promet de geler
l'urbanisme pendant un an deux ans le
temps de se mettre d'accord je trouve ça
pas très respectueux des électeurs
finalement parce que c'est pas tenable
tout à l'heure monsieur je parlais de
l'abstention je crois qu'on a quand même
et c'est pas que le cas voisins sur
cette dernière élection on voit partout
l'abstention gagne du terrain et je
crois que les électeurs prennent de la
distance avec laure leurs dirigeants
politiques parce qu'on leur a trop fait
de promesses on n'a jamais su tenir
sur l'urbanisme sur cathy de la remise
qui arrive est clair que voisin besoin
de logements la population vieillit on
manque de familles jeunes au manque
d'enfant je disais que les assistantes
maternelles à la rentrée c'est en euros
plus d'enfants à garder ce qui est un
vrai problème social il faut absolument
construire des logements pour accueillir
m les jeunes ménages accueillir les
familles en difficulté et a sombré la
prochaine saison par tour le parcours
résidentiel sur le paco facilement
construire ceci étant dit construire ne
signifie pas galvauder le cadre de vie
des chinois
loin de là on peut construire un voisin
tout en maintenant le cadre de vie des
chinois il ya peu d'espacé foncier c'est
vrai la remise et hall principal mais il
ya de quoi faire tout en maintenant la
qualité de vie et je dis aux six mois
que il faut plus que les constructions
nouvelles soit exemplaire d'une vision
val avenir et notamment nous défendons
une vraie politique énergétique est une
vraie politique énergétique et
écologique pour les nouveaux quartiers
notamment la remise donc des
écoquartiers de la concertation aussi
bien évidemment la consultation olivier
affonso vous êtes plutôt d'accord
j'imagine avec 6 10 il faut maîtriser
l'urbanisme attendait parce que quand on
parle de deux promesses et qu'il faut
pas dire n'importe quoi thierry castola
raison l'absence de l'absentéisme est un
vrai problème et quand on passe de 40 kg
au pardon quand on passe de 40% l'année
dernière ce qui était le score de
monsieur biette à 17% si vous estimez
que c'est un succès je vous félicite moi
aujourd'hui je considère que ce qui a
été fait n'était pas à faire ça ça n'a
pas été fait correctement
regarder un petit peu promenez-vous les
bâtiments qui ont été faits quand vous
ouvrez une fenêtre vous tombez sur votre
voisin au niveau des magasins ils sont
quasiment tous fermés parce qu'il n'ya
pas de places de stationnement on estime
que l'urbanisme a besoin aujourd'hui est
une réussite un vrai succès quand on
construit à la remise la remise je suis
tout à fait favorable à la construction
il faut pas car été caricaturé un petit
peu nos positions mais faire de la
remise d'un futur ghetto je ne suis pas
d'accord 500 logements c'est énorme
après effectivement il faut voir le
projet puisque aujourd'hui le projet on
en parle on parle de nombre de logements
sais même pas de quoi on parle
aujourd'hui ce qu'on sait c'est que l on
est à peu près à 36,46 40% peut-être un
logement combien dont 1 36% ce seront
des logements sociaux mais pour qui les
logements sociaux on sait que sur 1 100
logements sociaux on attribue peut-être
15 ovi sinois le reste est dispatché par
la préfecture vous avez un peu d avance
sur le temps de parole alors je vais
vous arrêter on va voir les chronomètres
qui vont s'afficher je vais vous faire
réagir chacun jean h oui moi je voudrais
quand même dire les vieux morceaux que
c'est pas parce que voisin ne distribue
que 15 % n'a fait que quatre tours de
logements sociaux que les logements
sociaux sont occupées par n'importe qui
non mais vous l'avez sous entendu j'ai
mis dix neuf ans en attendant de les
logements sociaux doivent être
que les logements sociaux soit réservé
aux villes chinoises ce qui n'est pas
pensable pas du tout votre j'ai bien
noté ce que vous avez dit parce que vous
êtes en retard qu'il faut ce n'est pas
10 à
dédramatiser un petit peu le problème du
logement social parce que 75% de la
population française peut il prétendre
aujourd'hui quand même on voit nous dans
les attributions qu'on a fait cette
année ce qu'on a plus de mal à attribuer
ce sont les grands logements sociaux en
dire au niveau supérieur ce qu'on
appelle le pls on a énormément de mal
attribué parce que un couple doit avoir
à peu près un revenu de 5000 euros pour
y accéder donc le logement social il ya
quand même différente différentes
strates on va dire et ça doit répondre
aux besoins non seulement évidemment des
vies si noah mais aussi du bassin de vie
puisqu'on a des entreprises qui
n'arrivent pas à loger leurs leurs
employés donc ils sont obligés d'aller
habiter très loin ils reviennent là et
sur le pourcentage d'attribution la
casse qui a également un pourcentage
d'attribution qu'elle nous je dirais
qu'elle nous reverse plus ou moins ou en
tout cas
au total en totale on est là on est à 20
% et puis ensuite
avec les bailleurs sociaux je vois sur
la villa où fleure le bailleur social a
aussi attribué lui même des logements
sociaux des vies sinois de toute façon
et je pense qu'aussi ça dépend aussi du
choix du bailleur c'est à dire qu'il
faut choisir un bailleur dont on sait
que ça se passe bien avec lui moi je
suis absolument anti ghetto ce que veut
nous faire le gouvernement aujourd'hui
c'est justement ça dans les prévisions
du géant tendue ce matin on va on va
tous concentrés au même endroit donc
c'est sûrement pas ça qu'on veut voilà
est ce qu'on veut c'est que mais aussi
des seniors parce qu'on a eu cette année
l'occasion d'attribuer des logements des
personnes âgées qui n'ont plus ces
moyens là donc ça je pense qu'il faut
dédramatiser un petit peu ce problème là
et faire des tailles de logements qui
correspondent aux besoins gastaud vous
faire agir aussi sur ceux sur ce sujet
de l'urbanisme sauvage heures et allez-y
vous avez 30 a besoin comme ça risque à
égalité effectivement il ya mis le
lecteur à droite qui ne sont pas venues
aux urnes se ferment appareils se sont
pas reportées sur la liste d'olivier
donc aujourd hui en a mille électeurs
qui s'étaient situés à droite l'année
dernière qui sont absents et parce que
je pense qu'il boude eboot de voir une
ump divisé et je pense qu'on aurait pu
trouver des solutions aux premier et
deuxième tours maintenant sur le
logement moi je rejoins alexandra là
dessus je pense que forcément c'est un
sujet
difficile à voisin parce qu'on a un
cadre de vie remarquable et il faut
réconcilier les gens avec cette notion
là il faut arrêter de se faire peur de
les opposer les uns aux autres la
dernière fois on entendait le mot je ne
veux pas habiter dans une cité
aujourd'hui c'est le mot ghetto le
logement social à voisins sont ni des
cités ni des ghettos ni des barres hlm
je pense qu'il faut être un peu mesuré
on a des programmes avec de la mixité à
chaque fois de l'acquisition du logement
social et le logement social c'est
effectivement nos enfants nos amis une
femme seule aujourd'hui avec deux
enfants pour se loger en ile de france
il lui faut un accès au logement social
si on peut afficher à présent les les
temps de parole le ton que ce qu'ils
s'affichent et irrigue à stockhom vous
avez à peu près 30 secondes de retard je
vais vous laisser la parole pour
commencer à parler de la circulation
parce qu'on parle de logements bien
évidemment mais aussi des routes pour
tout ça et la circulation c'est déjà un
problème à voisins-le-bretonneux alors
quelle solution vient on nous parle de
l'état c'est vrai qu'à une politique de
l'eau nassif mais le département doit
nous aider sur les problèmes de
circulation alors je sais qu'aujourd'hui
à des grosses contraintes économiques on
trouve pas de l'argent partout comme on
veut nous on est porteur d'un projet
mais qui existe en opéré lui depuis de
longues années qui est la nouvelle
percée d'une voie d'accès à la rd 36
depuis le coeur de ville parce que pour
moi la solution 7 permettent aux
vicinaux à de sortir du coeur de ville
le plus rapidement possible et par
contre il faut travailler sur une
solution contournement de la ville pour
les automobilistes qui nous viennent
principalement matin de la vallée de
chevreuse et il faut trouver une
solution pour fluidifier ces deux
carrefours sur la rd 36 que sont les
pyramides et le lac le long du rd 91 et
là ça peut se faire qu'en cohésion avec
le département
oui la circulation n'est pas un problème
de vu si loin c'est un problème parce de
plus vastes que ça il est clair que
voilà tout seul ne peut pas résoudre le
problème tout au mieux on peut proposer
des améliorations à certaines heures de
la journée pour fluidifier la
circulation de transit pour notre part
là je rejoins ce que 10-15 tôt il nous
semble qu'il faut vraiment travailler le
carrefour de la rd 36 avec la venue des
pyramides et le carrefour de la d 36
avec la route de guyancourt pour aller
après vers l'a86 mais tout ça ça suppose
qu'on mette ensemble voisin
l'agglomération et le département et sur
la numération à ce que c'est faisable on
dirait siégé pendant un an ben oui on a
commencé à y travailler avec
l'agglomération et le département
justement d'où le le
l'expérimentation et du carrefour rue
hélène-boucher cédé 36 qui est une
expérience point bloquant non c'est une
expérimentation celle là elle avait pour
but de fluidifier la traversée de
voisins le matin il est évident qu'avec
en plus la remise il faut absolument
qu'on travaille sur l'autre carrefour
mais bon tout prend tu prends du temps
évidemment et puis la question du budget
devra être devrait être soulevée puisque
la au budget de 2015 sur le département
il n'y a rien de prévu donc il faudra
qu'en 2016 des études soit prévue et
puis que les choses s'enchaînent ça veut
dire qu'il faut reporter à plus tard
même si à des constructions de logements
là certains se sont fait un logement ne
vont pas sortir de terre en 2015 donc ça
nous laisse quand même le temps de
travailler dessus mais évidemment il
faut travailler dessus mais il faut
enfin moi je donne pas de solution
miracle je pense que dès qu'on touche à
un endroit ça bloque un autre endroit ça
m'est donc c'est vraiment une vraie vue
d'ensemble qu'il faut avoir pourquoi pas
cette idée peut-être une autre
faut vraiment avoir cette vision
d'ensemble et puis pour la partager avec
les gens parce que c'est très facile
d'inquiéter des gens en leur racontant
on va leur mettre des des voix aura de
leur maison etc moi je peux le faire
aussi y'a pas de soucis mais je pense
qu'il faut être raisonnable sur ce sujet
et puis poser les choses dans leur
ensemble parce que les gens peuvent
comprendre que si on les avantages d'un
côté on va peut-être des avantages et
d'un donc il faut arriver à trouver un
juste milieu
voudrais dire que j'ai jamais entendu
des gens dire qu'on a l'habitude de voir
leur maison
je ne sais pas par quoi je m'en fais pas
pour moi je ne connais pas ça mais ce
que je voulais je voulais revenir sur
l'aménagement de la remise l'aménagement
de la remise du roi de sens que si on
aménage également le carrefour entre la
rue des pyramides et la nuit de la cité
36 et donc il faut vraiment voir le
problème dans sa complexité dans sa
globalité et non pas par petites touches
au bain ça me fait un peu sourire quand
on trouve des idées magique alors qu'on
a été vingt ans aux manettes et quand on
m'explique que la construction c'est
formidable à voisins on a toujours
construit on s'est toujours posé la
question de la circulation après alors
qu'il aurait fallu faire l' inverse je
suis d'accord avec madame rosetti a pas
de solution miracle donc la voie
contournement par le sud je pense qu'il
faut un petit peu levitt et d'en parler
je pense que c'était une promesse
intenable et je pense qu'on est tout à
fait pas une promesse non c'est un
engagement que vous avez fait à long
terme
ce que je veux dire par là c'est qu'on
est obligé de mettre toutes les forces
vives de notre ville autour de autour
d'une table je crois à l'intelligence
collective je pense qu'il faut réfléchir
à tout ce qu'on a pu lui proposer parce
que on propose tous ses solutions dans
le cadre d'une campagne une fois que les
la campagne est terminée tout le monde
range sa promesse dans sa poche donc il
faut effectivement la casse qui avec une
force une voix assez forte au niveau de
la casse qui parce que sinon si les
autres ne font pas d'efforts nous on est
sur on subit fortement aujourd'hui
vraiment fortement le problème de la
circulation effectivement on compte sur
madame rosetti qui aura cette double
casquette et qui va sûrement nous
trouver des solutions en concertation et
en concertation avec les riverains et
avec la future opposition vous parlez de
l'intercommunalité justement
l'intercommunalité à partir de janvier
2016 normalement ces cinq nouvelles
communes plaisir villepreux les
claymores pas coignières ce sera 1er
janvier quelle place pour voisins le
bretonneux est ce que c'est une bonne ou
une mauvaise chose est-ce que voisins
aura suffisamment de poids pour se faire
entendre thierry gastaud commencer ce
tour de table soit cette question remis
en question qui va se poser elle sera
technique c'est que normalement notre
assemblée sera limitée en nombre de
sièges donc il faudra voir si l'ensemble
des des conseillers sont d'accord pour
augmenter son nombre de sièges ou s'il
faut se limiter à ce qui est prévu par
la loi et à ce moment là ça sera des
réductions de sièges pour chaque ville
mais je pense pas que la question se
pose de savoir si les villes sont
représentées par trois ou cinq élus
finalement voisins la pesée moins
qu'avant c'est sûr maintenant nous
sommes une ville totalement enclavé dans
l'agglo toutes nos toutes nos frontières
sont avec des villes non de la même
intercommunalité ça nous donne un rôle
peut-être pas de ville centre on n'est
pas montini mais un rôle primordial et
notamment sur ces questions de
circulation et sur cet axe vers saclay
qui risque aussi de se développer dans
le futur
alors moi j'ai toujours regretté que nos
délégués à la casse qui ne travaillez
pas suffisamment ne rendez pas compte
suffisamment la population de tout faire
et en plus si tu es à la traîne des
autres communes donc ça j'ai regretté et
j'espère que les nouveaux délégués de
voisins seront effectivement des
délégués qui travailleront pas ce que
l'avenir de voisins ne se passe pas un
voisin il se passe au niveau
intercommunal il faut absolument que
voisin soit volontaire au niveau de la
casse qui ce qui n'a pas été le cas
jusqu'à maintenant je suis 10e des
dix-sept désolé sandra mais ça s'est
fait dans la vie tu es j'ai déjà dit je
peux le redire j'ai participé le pl oui
j'ai été énormément déçu par la
table
et je le dis publiquement
oui bon pour me dire que j'ai pas
travailler avec mes élus qui étaient là
n'ont pas travaillé je trouve ça un
petit peu gonflé parce que vu le temps
qu'on y passe et l'énergie qu'on y
déploie je suis je suis non je perds pas
mon temps je passe énormément de temps à
travailler avec les services
aménagements en particulier pour le pays
et lui j'ai vraiment beaucoup travaillé
j'ai fait des réunions de concertation
les gens ne viennent pas aux réunions de
concertation donc si je vous ai déçu je
suis vraiment désolé j'étais en train de
faire je voulais faire des propositions
justement ovi sinois sur différents
secteurs de la ville pour que le feu et
lui puissent être bouclé en juin donc
non je travaille énormément et je pense
que mon positionnement nous mon nouveau
positionnement aussi au conseil
départemental
j'espère va contribuer à faire une place
à voisins dont au sein de cet
aménagement conseillère départementale
il faut être raisonnable la situation de
la circulation qui a été peu réglé dans
le passé
quand même position de voix dans
laquelle ce qui est du travail des
délégués de voix de la case qui est ce
que je dis des délégués qu'on vient de
perdre actuellement je le disais le cio
délégués dans les pôles - ce que je vous
réponds c'est qu'on paye le prix aussi
d'un héritage d'une gestion socialiste
était pas favorable à voisin pendant des
années sur sa cianas oro avait causé les
dégâts d'eau les jours n'avaient avant
de savourer programme est sur les genoux
enfin leur faut travailler
et je vous interromps tous les trois
pour ne pas laisser la parole la parole
aux opus h l'apport le plus sage oui à
fond sur cette question de
l'intercommunalité qui va s'élargir
bonnes nouvelles choses et la place de
votre torchon généreux c'est assez
étonnant c'est tellement rare non
l'intercommunalité le pardon oui
effectivement la place de goise
m'inquiète mais c'est là qu'on arrive à
un carrefour important on a loupé lui il
va falloir très bien de négocier il faut
absolument que voisin je dirais que ce
pays lui servent à voisins que ce soit
pas en local sur balles à pardon excusez
ma yi sierra jeu commencera
effectivement donc effectivement on
arrive à un carrefour et c'est ça qui
m'inquiète aujourd'hui c'est pas
l'élargissement de la caisse qui
ici les pardon mais on est tous d'accord
enfin peut-être page en âge mais on est
tous d'accord aujourd'hui ce qui
m'inquiète c'est le pen lui c'est
l'outil indispensable pour protéger
voisins et la madame rosetti qui sera
élu maire de voisin probablement
dimanche sauf un cas exceptionnel mais
je lui demande franchement de travailler
et de faire en sorte que le pen lui
protège notre ville c'est le dernier
outil qui peut nous protéger voilà je le
dis clairement il n'y a pas de je
soutiendrai madame rosetti à ce moment
là parce que c'est de l'avenir de notre
vie qu'il s'agit et l'avenir et l'avenir
pardon de quartier on va passer aux
conclusions il nous reste quelques
minutes ceux des émissions on va
afficher les chronomètres de chacun on
va commencer avec vous alexandra rosetti
pour faire le tour de table dans le même
sens sur la conclusion le message aux
électeurs vis sinoise héninoise mon
message c'est d'abord qu'il se déplace
dimanche aurait d'abord jamais gagné
d'avancé et puis je pense que c'est
important parce que c'est le c'est de
l'avenir de leur ville qu'il s'agit et
puis un petit mot aussi pour leur dire
que en ce moment c'est un peu ambiance
peur sur la ville tout est fait pour je
dirais affolé par des rumeurs
complètement insensé qui circulent donc
voilà leur demander de raison garder et
puis voilà de faire des procurations
sinon s'ils ne peuvent tenir ce dimanche
tiré castro pour faire réagir une
trentaine de secondes pour conclure je
crois qu'il faut que voisins aient
confiance en son avenir on a un riche
passé on peut avoir confiance en notre
avenir il faut se rassembler on voit
qu'il ya plein de sujets où on a des
sujets où on est d'accord sur le fond
tout à l'heure on parlait que ce
deuxième tour était là pour désigner la
principale liste d'opposition c'est pas
ma vision des choses je pense qu'on aura
un maire et délices de minorités mais
qu'il faudra qu'on travaille ensemble
sur ces sujets là pour le quotidien des
piscines -
oui moi je considère je vais dire
d'entrée que l'enjeu de ce deuxième tour
ce n'est pas le maire puisque on sait
que ça sera alexandre arrosée qui
s'est effectivement la construction du
conseil municipal donc l'opposition il
explique spatiaux montré qu'une
opposition droite droite était toujours
inefficace terrier et se limiter à des
querelles de personnes alors que nous et
moi personnellement je suis élu depuis
20 ans donc et toujours dans
l'opposition j'ai toujours eu un
comportement d'opposition constructive
au service des victimes et sans chercher
la moindre connaissance à titre
personnel et je veux que ceux ci
continuent je veux qu'ils aient une
opposition forte et que cette opposition
majoritaire ce soit nous
pour conclure et c'est la fin de cette
édition très bien il nous faut une il
faut qu'on se rassemble clairement il
faut une opposition constructive nous
pose une opposition probablement
positive et quand j'entends mon
concurrent principal concurrent dire
qu'il faut se rassembler quand on voit
le dernier tract qui l' aquila qui l'a
diffusée dans la ville je pense qu'on
n'a pas même n'a pas du tout la même
notion du rassemblement donc il faut
tourner la page de ces dernières années
il faut une un conseil municipal apaisé
rassembler autour de ce qui nous unit
notre ville merci à tous les quatre un
dernier coup d'oeil au chronomètre vous
avez globalement le même temps de parole
environ cinq minutes pour vous exprimer
second tour de cette municipale
partielle à voisins le bretonneux elle
ce sera dimanche 19 avril et puis le
point complet les résultats lundi 18h
dans le journal de la rédaction très
bonne soirée